hey i'm ryan right and i'm jerry so
today we're gonna be watching the
trailer for transcendence which makes me
think of a woman with a penis
transgender transfer and Emmas I hear
travelling of sex things I don't think
that's actually what transgender means
hmm all right let's do this Jer bear
we're doing it watching it's been
approved for people to you I know they
changed that card reasonably and
requires us lock the most fundamental
secrets of the universe most fundamental
seekers of the universe with Disney
Concert Hall full of human emotion I'm
so excited looks like he's actually
acting our greater collective
intelligence every person in the history
this is
to them talk
that's the entire wall it was crazy
oh yeah it looks trippy as [ __ ] yeah I
am excited for this I'm really excited
and wildly confused at the same time
yeah that is really excited this is the
first show I've seen a mile in a while
this made me go I cannot wait yeah yeah
it just looks awesome that this did me
and the DP the stuff looks really cool
obviously well III don't think wally
pfister would be capable Thank You
marine it didn't look good it has that
Nolan feel - as you can tell he's
totally inspired by while working on
this films with him stuff well yeah I
mean he spent like most like the first
half his career and no idea and I was
moving on the second plan I'm really
[ __ ] excited for Johnny Depp oh
here's something
work on transgender